auch heute wollen wir einen blick werfen
auf den brutalen krieg putins gegen die
ukraine wir müssen uns noch einmal
ansehen dieses unfassbare
kriegsverbrechen von gestern in der
stadt kammerchors im osten der ukraine
hat putin mit einer ballistischen rakete
auf einen bahnhof voller flüchtender
zivilisten geschossen hat dabei 52
menschen ermordet wir sehen uns noch
einmal an warum ist kratos so wichtig
für putin warum ist das ganze so zu
sagen ihm so viel wert dass er dort auf
zivilisten schießen lässt kantors ist
die größte verbleibende stadt im osten
der ukraine die größte stadt in der
region gut nomads die noch vollständig
von der ukraine beherrscht wird und hier
wissen wir dass putin seit mehreren
tagen versucht einen kessel aufzubauen
ein kessel aus norden aus der region
kaki von süden aus der region rund um
mario pohl und er wird dort die 30.000
soldaten etwa die dort ukrainischen
soldaten die dort vor ort sind
einkesseln das ist ihnen bislang nicht
gelungen und offenbar geht es nun wieder
so dass er auf absoluten terror setzt
das er ballistische raketen gegen zu
evakuieren der zivilisten einsetze ja
unter umständen um diesen prozess zu
beschleunigen oder um einfach diesem
terror zu verbreiten um die zivilisten
aus dem weg zu kriegen wir gucken uns
ein video an von gestern es ist ziemlich
verstört muss ich sagen wir haben
selbstverständlich gepixelt aber es
zeigt die minuten direkt nach dem
angriff es zeigt tote frauen und kinder
vor allem frauen und kinder war ja genau
die evakuiert werden sollen am bahnhof
von kratos' am bahnhof an dem ich selber
schon mal auf einen zug gewartet habe
insofern umso umso unfassbarer auch
diese aufnahmen und was wir sehen ist
inmitten dieser dieser ganzen toten die
dort liegen der schwerverletzten
teilweise eine ziemlich einmalige szene
nämlich ich lasse mir ganz kurz noch
laufen wir sehen eine deutsche fahne
dort
so ganz etwa hier einmal kurz zurück
kurz zurück und versuchen das anzusehen
eine fahne der bundesrepublik
deutschland die hier aufgebaut ist oder
je auf einem banner darauf ist darunter
steht auf ukrainischen darunter auch
deutsch deutsche zusammenarbeit das ist
ein projekt des entwicklungsministeriums
der bundesrepublik deutschland dass dort
erst um mitte märz um den 15 bis 19 märz
herum zelte hin geliefert hat um eben zu
helfen um den flüchtlingen zu helfen
aber es zeigt eben auch auf sehr brutale
art und weise was deutschland liefert
nämlich humanitäre unterstützung
unterstützung um eben diesen
flüchtlingen zu helfen bei der flucht
aber eben nicht militärische
unterstützung um solche art von attacken
abzuhalten insofern dass ein ziemlich ja
ein ziemlich zweischneidiges zeugnis
sozusagen der deutschen unterstützung
dort wir wollen uns noch ein video der
rakete an sind die dort benutzt wurde
ich werde hier noch mal anhalten das ist
das antriebs segment der rakete die dort
eingesetzt wurde dass sich sozusagen
kurz vor dem einschlag abgesprengt hat
und vorne sind dann diese streumunition
herausgekommen die streubomben die also
den menschen dort die die körper
zerfetzt haben hinten blick das liegen
zynischerweise mit dem russischen
propaganda aufdruck dt also für die
kinder war es auf dieser rakete darauf
stand wurde erst abgeschossen und das
unfassbare ist ja dass russland
daraufhin gesagt hat ja ihr seht doch
diese waffe solche waffen haben wir
überhaupt nicht solche waffen nämlich
trotz dieser rakete oder ss 21 ist der
nato name für sie die haben wir seit
jahren nicht mehr in unsere nationalen
sowas hat nur die ukraine so was nutzen
wir gar nicht mehr und wir wollen an
dieser stelle zeigen dass auch dies eine
unfassbare propagandalüge des putin
regimes ist wir haben hier neue
aufnahmen von anfang april die uns
erreichen wir lassen das einfach mal
laufen hier wird aus einem zug ein
anderer zug gefilmt und diese andere zug
zeigt genau diese trotz ko system genau
dieses system die putin eingesetzt hat
um eben dort zivilisten anzugreifen und
wir sehen uns das noch mal zu zeigen
hier dieses zeichen dass v eines der
zeichen wir wissen dass das z das v das
soeben die symbole sind der russischen
armee um in die verschiedenen einheiten
der verschiedenen fronten voneinander zu
unterscheiden
mit lass uns noch mal ganz kurz
abspielen umzusehen es handelt sich
tatsächlich um einen gesamten zug von
diesem system alle mit den russischen
markt darauf der eben hier zwischen
belarus und der ukraine hin und her
bewegt wurde um diese raketen zum
einsatz zu bringen die wahrheit ist also
ja putin hat diese systeme vor jahren
aus dem dienst gestellt aber nein er hat
sie nicht im ruhestand gelassen sondern
benutzt sie jetzt erneut um in dem
rainer anzugreifen um relativ billig mit
alten sowjetischen raketen hier
zivilisten umzubringen
kleiner sprung zu einem anderen thema es
gibt auch einige gute nachrichten für
die ukraine nämlich ein erstes nato-land
die slowakei hat zum ersten mal jetzt
ein schweres flugabwehrsystem an die
ukraine geliefert nämlich eine s-300 das
ist ein system auch sowjetischer bauart
was aber sehr modernes was ein sehr
großer reichweite hat
bisher vergleichsweise modernes und
diese aufnahmen können wir
veröffentlichen weil das system bereits
in der ukraine angekommen ist gestern
gab es sozusagen eine ein gros der
slowakischen regierung dass dieses video
jetzt veröffentlicht werden darf weil
dieses system angekommen ist die s-300
kann flugzeuge abfangen in bis zu 150
kilometer entfernung und 25 kilometer
höhe und fast genauso wichtig sie hat
einen modernen rader wir sehen dass hier
ein großes radarsystem was man
aufstellen kann was 300 kilometer weit
russische flugzeuge entdecken kann dass
man also zumindest auch den alarm
auslösen kann und und die menschen in
sicherheit bringen kann ein solches
radar oder ein solches system man muss
es sagen wenn es denn in der ost ukraine
stationiert gewesen wäre hätte die
chance gehabt diesen angriff von gestern
vielleicht zu unterbinden die slowakei
hat nur ein einziges davon hat dieses
eine system der ukraine zur verfügung
gestellt damit sie sich verteidigen kann
das ist sozusagen ein guter anfang aber
die ukraine braucht wesentlich mehr um
das ganze land vor putins attacken wie
dieser gestern mit 52 toten zivilisten
zu schützen